[Music]
two successful doctors in Texas are
accused of hiring a hitman and a bizarre
murder plot
Valerie McDaniel and Leon Jacob fell in
love and planned to get married but
legal issues with their former partners
created problems 48 hours correspondent
Peter Van Zant got an exclusive
interview with the man who posed as a
hitman drawn out story that's led
conclusion this is the voice of dr.
Valerie McDaniel recording an audio
diary in 2017 this recently divorced
veterinarian began dating a surgeon
Leon Jacob I looked at him and smiled
and he smiled back and just a beautiful
person she had this outwardly
exuberance of energy that I really can't
describe we were planning on getting
married but there were obstacles a
stalking charge by Leon's ex-girlfriend
who could derail his surgical career and
a custody battle between Valerie and her
ex-husband he was a narcissist so in the
spring of 2017
authorities say Leon hatched a
diabolical plan my name is Montez Ozzie
and then Jacob tried to hire me as a him
TAS says he was paid to silence Leon's
girlfriend and kill Valerie's ex but he
says he never intended to kill anyone
are you a hit man no were you ever
willing to murder anyone for money no no
no I would never do something like that
instead Tazz agreed to work with Houston
police in an elaborate undercover sting
operation police even got the potential
victims
Valerie's ex-husband and Leon's
ex-girlfriend to stage pictures as if
the crimes had occurred
it was a Hollywood moment when cops
entered Valerie and Leon's condo to
bring their dramatic sting operation to
an end
[Music]
but moments later Houston woman and her
boyfriend were charged with trying to
have their exes killed I could never
hurt the man that my daughter loves so
much I think that she was in a very
vulnerable position when she met Leon
Jacob I think he influenced her and
brainwashed her
for those who believe I'm looking into
the eyes of essentially a killer what do
you want those people to know I'm
innocent I take no pleasure in having to
interview with 48 hours about this and
Peter Van Zandt is with us now so Peter
in full disclosure a crazy coincidence
I know Leon very well I went to college
with him and his ex-wife was one of my
good friends in college so I spent a lot
of time with him because of her I have
to say he did raise some red flags
amongst friends but but nothing to this
degree how is he doing now well he's in
jail awaiting trial and he has flipped
on the woman he said he loved more than
any on earth saying that if he had never
met Valerie McDaniel none of this would
have happened to him and he says she
bankrolled all of this prosecutors
though believe that's just a ridiculous
story that he was the mastermind behind
this how did two doctors end up hiring a
hitman I know you guys hired a hit man
yeah so they'd been complaining about
their exes she'd gone through this
bitter divorce talking around the office
somebody said well you know I know this
person who was an ex Iraq war veteran
he's of Middle Eastern extraction they
did a little profiling thought gee
they'd kill somebody they hooked that
them up but the hit man turned out to be
a hero in this because he just was was
tagging them along and then he brought
in Houston police and he helped nail
these two story gave me chills when I
first heard about it a few years ago and
of course now bringing it back to life
there's no the same chills did your
friend ever say Leon posed a danger to
her I didn't really say in touch with
her but I knew that it was a really
messy and ugly divorce yeah fascinating
story thank you Peter thank you Peter
and you can see Peters report 48 hours
operation murder
Morrow night at 10:00 9:00 central right
here on CBS